bienvenue dans l'atelier nolty où nous
assemblons préparons l'intégralité des
aménagements s'évader à moindre coût
pour ces vacances c'est la promesse de
nolti spécialisée dans la conception de
kit amovible pour véhicules utilitaire
cuisine couchage rangement la société
située aujourd'hui à Garancières a été
fondée en 2018 elle propose un mobilier
universel s'adaptant à la plupart des
habitacles objectifs rendre le milieu du
caravaning moins onéreux si on arrivait
pour faire simple à créer un aménagement
et de pouvoir le proposer à un tarif ma
voisinant les 2500 euros avec la literie
et l'expédition c'était Paris gagné seul
quelques inserts métalliques sont placés
dans le plancher par la société nolti le
kit en bois peuplier est ensuite livré
sur palette au domicile de l'acheteur et
fixé grâce à ses visuels l'idée c'était
vraiment de créer un aménagement
amovible que les clients puissent
installer au bord de leur propre
véhicule et sans outilillage ce client
désiré voyager de manière spontanée pose
de vitrage feutrine habillage bois pour
environ 5000 euros son véhicule
utilitaire a pu être aménagé pour lui
permettre de partir en week-end donc là
vous avez un couchage d'un mètre 80 sur
120 large OK et ensuite l'intégralité
des matelas qui viennent tout simplement
se positionner
de cette façon je voulais un kit qui
soit qui fasse le vraiment la double
utilité je passe du côté camion
camionnette aux côtés vannes très très
rapidement et c'est surtout que c'est
nettement moins cher qu'un camping-car
ou quoi que ce soit donc il y a un côté
économique et écologique de plus voilà
de plutôt que d'avoir effectivement un
van
aménagé de façon fixe pour s'en servir 4
à 5 semaines par an et tout le reste du
temps qu'il soit stationné à son
domicile on trouvait ça un petit peu
dommage avec une demande croissante
depuis la pandémie de covid 19 la
société nolti expedding quinzaine de
kits chaque mois chez ses clients un
besoin de prendre la route pour s'évader
et aller à l'aventure